Así es por lo menos es una de las más
poderosas que han entrado por la costa
oeste de la Península de la Florida
Florida tiene dos costas la costa oeste
que da hacia el golfo de México y la
costa Oriental que da hacia el Océano
Atlántico Por supuesto que por su
ubicación geográfica es el paso casi
obligado de ciclones que van hacia la
Unión Americana este ciclón tomó una
trayectoria muy particular porque una
vez que pasó por el norte de Venezuela
ya ingresado en las aguas del Caribe y
comenzó a tomar fuerza se esperaba que
su trayectoria se moviera hacia el oeste
hacia la Península de Yucatán e
internarse al Golfo de México sin
embargo tomó una un rumbo un cambio de
dirección de 90 grados para cruzar con
rumbo Norte la punta occidental de Cuba
y después pues dirigirse hacia Florida
pero una vez que cruzó Cuba en categoría
3 todavía se fortaleció hasta la
categoría 4 de la esca de Huracanes
tocando el día de hoy Florida Casi casi
a punto de la categoría 5 que es la
máxima ahora Mauro vemos por ejemplo en
redes sociales las impresionantes
imágenes de la devastación causada por
Ian podríamos presenciar daños tan
graves como los que dejó el huracán
Katrina en 2005
probablemente no y te voy a decir por
qué principalmente es por la condición
geográfica de la Florida la Florida por
ser una península es un terreno digamos
primero plano y segundo estrecho
entonces en horas va a cruzar la Florida
entrando muy cerca de key coral o cerca
de punta gorda y después desplazándose
hacia la zona de Orlando para abandonar
o emergir nuevamente hacia las aguas del
Atlántico el caso particular de
Louisiana es difícil porque tiene una
elevación inclusive por debajo del nivel
del agua por eso ahí los daños fueron
catastróficos bien era Mauro Morales
meteorólogo de la cadena televisa en
Monterrey Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en directo América
un placer buenas noches